[Music]
one of the most common themes
in my work as an executive coach is
what i call essentially people problems
you know almost all my clients
are our ceos um the vast majority of
them are
are leaders of some group of people and
the dilemma that they face that they
want to work with me on is is you know
the difficulties that they're
experiencing
you know in some cases with the people
they lead and manage in other cases with
their peers
in in other cases with uh investors or
other
uh stakeholders or authority figures and
and in that work i'm reminded
of a great line from the eminent french
film director jean renoir
and he says the the hell of life is that
everyone has their reasons
and and that's really important to
remind ourselves of when we're when we
are met with somebody whose behavior we
find you know frustrating or maddening
or confusing uh you know we we often
leap to some assumptions
about the fact that they're um uh
you know we we assume that that they're
that they lack understanding we assume
that they're you know that they're
acting out of you know spite or
capriciousness
you know we make a whole host of
assumptions which often uh you know
justify our own perspective
and are typically very unempathetic and
what we
fail to do habitually is stop and and
ask ourselves
what is that person's reason you know i
find their behavior
maddening or frustrating they're getting
in the way it somehow
and what we need to do is slow ourselves
down and remind ourselves
everyone has their reasons very rarely
in life
do we actually do we encounter an actual
social you know very rarely do we
encounter somebody who's deliberately
going out of their way to screw things
up and
and make things difficult for us it's
much more often the case
almost universally the case that when we
find ourselves in conflict
um it's about misunderstandings and and
and missed expectations
and incorrect assumptions and so so much
of my work
entails encouraging people to slow down
examine the assumptions that they're
making about the other person
develop a theory of mind what is what is
governing this other person what are
their beliefs and assumptions what are
their goals
and can i allow that information to
inform how i approach them
so rather than assuming you know they're
uh you know they're they're coming here
to
you know they're they're taking these
steps and actions to kind of mess me up
and get in my way
um can i take a broader perspective on
what might be
driving them what what impulses or
reasoning
might be informing their behavior it's
also important to bear in mind that in
some sense
all behavior is adaptive and so when we
run into
behavior that we find frustrating or
confusing it's important to ask
ourselves
well what are they adapting to and for a
leader it's
especially important to ask you know are
they adapting to me
am i in some sense creating a condition
that they're
finding the need to adapt to that that
you know i might find frustrating so is
there something i
can do to change how i'm showing up and
influence
the environment in which this other
person is operating
you